so scrolls are the bad guys  and you're free a race of noble boys  heroes noble warrior heroes  [Music]  your life began the day it nearly ended  we found you with no memory we made you  one of us so you could live longer  stronger superior  you were reborn  I keep having these  memories something in my past is the key  to all of this  you're not a fly this thing you'll see  that's a yes or no question yes  [Music]  would you like to know  what you really are  I think I had a life here  what are you telling me  you've come a long way  but you know as strong as you think  the small cysts the beginning I'm not  gonna fight your war  [Music]  I'm gonna end it  [Music]  aren't you the cutest lovely aren't you  yeah what's your name Jerry's  you